scanner for lowrider mana you know the
rules
I don't have to explain them but I will
do it anyway if you lass
you will lose squats floor very simple
rules you can begin this challenge right
now by smashing that like button let's
freakin do this guy's if this video hits
a line then you are supporting a really
bad cause ha ha got you that in that bed
you thought I was gonna do something
good for people no all right good joke
let's begin let's begin everybody ok
I've seen this hooray
ok ok this is my face right now not
impress although it is a very good edit
probably stolen by someone all right
looks like so far so good
I'm still in it I'm still winning heck
yeah guys can we keep this up this is
the furthest we've ever come
[Music]
snake no no I did not laugh I just
humored myself
okay had nothing to do with the video I
got so bored I would think of other
things
what was the snake submission alright
okay moving I'm this Scottish accent is
famous for being difficult to understand
but the Glaswegian accent can be even
more difficult the last we jiin delasco
in norwegian Glaswegian I love the
Glaswegian accent and I was wondering if
you could teach me some local phrases
well it's very happy that I'm gonna be
mean this is a thing it's always it's
not eat me as always look London hope
you have his eyes understand oh you
don't understand
oh my god I thought I had it for a what
is it a joke is he just just have an
aneurysm I got well this is very hard to
bring out main dangus Springer bring her
main dingus bring a main dingus bring me
a dingus that's what he's saying
I think it's what he is always look one
day it's always I saw TV it's always
it's always it's what eat me it's always
look one day sorry sorry open your eyes
he hardly heard his eyes see it's not
that heard I understand okay
but you idiots that's a cute outfit did
your husband give it to you actually he
did he bought this for me on her 10-year
anniversary
not only is he my lover he's my best
friend
and my soul mate I'm not ashamed of who
I love nor should I be for someone with
strange abilities due to I assume
accidental exposure to radioactive
spider blood
you're not very tolerant of those
different to yourself you're on the
wrong side of history spider-man
I've seen this me before but honestly
Jack made it better
well done can you believe dis me posted
this blatant homophobia disgusting what
are they gonna do next fire someone over
some jokes what is this
no let's say 200,000 views yeah what is
this yeah stupid short ones what is yeah
in Japanese hi Google Translate yes yeah
II oh yeah oh it's a egg so he's going
hey Nunda Scott what the fries done
I bet they're not even half weep whoever
did the voice acting they should have
asked me I would have done a way better
job then
yeah Cheers your PewDiePie Wow
[Music]
No untrue markiplier breads didn't I
great beauty Potter better than the real
one hey what are you getting will make
me for food sub very nice I don't know
why I love this meat the smash made was
so good right now
[Music]
oh my god she says
[Applause]
[Music]
Mentos the freshmaker I mean I'd buy a
Mentos after that mentors please sponsor
me I need sponsors okay if you're a
company and like you just feel like you
have too much money I'll boost you have
you guys but what advice would you give
to kids like me who make youtube videos
but dream about having a life creating
films I would say I'd say well you got
to just take a deep breath and give up
no the system is rigged against you your
hard work and talent will not pay off
nothing in our way and we barely got
here you have no chance you're doing it
you know you are making films there's
this idea that like you're doing that
hooray for you you know I'm sure he
meant it no contradiction he's basically
telling him he's already achieved his
goal what I feel like my brain is too
slowed to have anything of value to say
to these I always mix them up as well
it's a common thing to do and I
completely understand they're very
they're very much the same thing from
now on do not get my videos to monetize
instead of saying the f-word I will just
go I can't even do it as good Jesus
if I do a killer Bible today
oh my god oh my god
that's how they won the war everybody
that's how they won the war flex tape
confirmed hey yes yes
[Music]
jobs in Nevada
the beautiful bastards don't even pay
attention
when do they welcome back to the free
let's just jump into it
[Music]
Michael here
this is too much nipples
[Music]
the boys Jack smells great
good one fine grande fine what do you
want a clap that's all you get it okay
I've seen this video this is epic okay
just what there's one there's the most
epic thought twists of all time because
who made this burger you're telling it
man so let me start I just want to ask
what is this documentary is is you know
just not ask directly
is this a fluff piece to make people
feel better about Logan Paul yeah
absolutely I mean yeah oh my god me
sitting you with you right now what what
went wrong in my life that I thought
that was a good idea
oh my god this is awkward I want to make
it very clear I am the fastest the
biggest the best the greatest do you
understand
I feel like this video doesn't even need
editing I am culturally insensitive to
make it awkward and insensitive when
when the whole world hates you
I just I made the conscious decision I'm
gonna I'm gonna tase a dead rat I mean
yeah and world when you look at this
young man he's a fighter doctor said he
has I live to help Carolyn
look at this man this man is suffering
from a chronic illness that's it for
Scott the devil Oh read new did you
laugh or did you lose if you lost like
if you didn't like subscribe if you
haven't already hit that subscribe
button and hit that subscribe button and
maybe if you have the chance leave a
like
goodbye everybody and goodbye goodbye